maurice is in atlanta
hi maurice how are you i'm doing fine
dave how are you and chris doing today
great man how can we help dave i got a
uh a two-part question if i could um i
have a question today about um bond down
your interest rate of points is that a
good idea a bad idea
as well as um having a pay for home
whether to sell it or to rent it out
okay um paid for how why would you sell
a paid for house
no um whether to risk the home out or
or either to sell the home do you want
to be a landlord or do you want the
money
get questions i mean that's up to you
you
you talking about the the home you're
living in is paid for you're going to
move to another house
yes but person's in another home then i
would sell it and use the money to
purchase the next home
because otherwise effectively you've
borrowed the money for a rental property
on your new house and i wouldn't do that
okay so because that's the mortgage part
of the equation too now it's coming to
me okay
so here's how points work all right
roughly
one point or one point is one percentage
point of the borrowed amount
so if you're borrowing two hundred
thousand dollars one point is
two thousand dollars that will reduce
your
interest rate your apr by anywhere from
one-eighth
to one-quarter in today's market more
like
one-eighth okay
and so if you had a three and an eighth
and you paid
one point you could buy it down to
around a three
does that make sense yes it does now
do this with me okay if you are getting
1
8 of a percent savings per year
as the payback of one percent
would it make sense to you that it takes
eight years
for that to break even
yes it does one-eighth times eight is
eight is a whole
okay eight-eighths is a whole is number
is one percent
and so an eight year break even period
on an interest rate you would not
do because
the average home the average home
mortgage is paid off every 5.6 years
and the average home sales every 7.1
years in america
okay and so you're not going to be there
long enough to even break even
and even if you were eight years to get
your freaking money back in a financial
transaction is
cray cray now
let's pretend that we did the math
because you're going to get a quote from
these guys you get a quote from
churchill mortgage right
and they come back and they say okay one
percent is going to reduce one percent
point is going to reduce your interest
rate
by a quarter now let's do the same
formula it takes
four years to get your money back if you
go from three and a quarter to
three by paying one point that's a much
better deal
obviously that one you might do
but you for sure don't do the other one
you you don't want to wait three
you don't want to wait more than four
years to get your money back on these
things
so the first four years you didn't make
any
profit any headway you're in the hole
until you get up to break even and it's
after four years or after eight years in
these two examples
that you get gravy on the biscuit
mathematically does that make sense
yes it does so overall when you run this
calculation i
think you're going to find i find about
9 out of 10 times
the answer to your question is do i use
points to buy down the interest rate
the answer is usually no yeah
maurice how much do you have in the bank
how much money do you have in the bank
right now
uh i actually have around 10 grand
okay because typically what would happen
is if you're dealing with a mortgage
company when they
start leading with buying down it's
because they're seeing the the
money you've put on your financial
statement that you have some money
sitting aside
and if they're typically leading with
the buy down it means
primarily that their interest rate is
not as competitive
as it needs to be so i just encourage
you to start with churchill
really take a look at that but be smart
about what you're doing as you're moving
forward